MAX SALTONSTALL: On this
episode of Stack Chat,
Spotify engineer
Matt Brown tells us
how Kubernetes helps power
the teams that power Spotify.
Increased deployments
and higher productivity
are just the start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for joining me, Matt.
So how does Spotify work?
MATT BROWN: When you use
Spotify on your laptop,
your mobile phone, a
speaker in your house,
your app is connected
to a layer of services
that we call the perimeter--
a series of gateways, load
balancers, things like that.
And then from there,
depending on what
you're doing in the app, you're
connected to one of hundreds
or probably about 1,000
different microservices that
are developed.
We used to run these
all in our data center.
But over the years, we've
moved fully to Google Cloud.
And those microservices, which
are all talking to each other,
are developed by about 200
different teams within Spotify.
And they're deploying
those, building
those independently based on--
one team might work on the
Search feature, the Playlist
feature, just different
features like that.
And then we have
another group of teams--
we have infrastructure
teams where we're
trying to build
tools for those teams
to move faster or do things
in a consistent way, things
like that.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
So how do you help
those many, many engineering
teams be able to focus on, I'm
going to build this
feature and then ship it,
whether to staging
or production,
and not have to worry about
all the infrastructure?
MATT BROWN: So we do a lot
as an infrastructure team
to try to make it very
simple to stand up
a new service, a new feature.
There is a framework
that you can
use that basically gives you
all the basics of building
a microservice,
handling RPC calls,
logging, connecting
to service discovery
to find the other services
you need to talk to.
We also make it very simple.
There's a single button you can
press in our developer console
to just create a new project,
new source code repo.
And you get all that stuff that
I mentioned before basically
for free.
You just code it
from a template.
So you're never really
starting from scratch.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And then you
have to manage all of these
and figure out how
they're going to actually
stay alive or scale.
And you built your own
system to do all that.
MATT BROWN: Yes, we did.
So we started to adopt Docker,
Docker containers, very early
on, I think before it
was even version 1.0.
And we were really
excited by it because it
added a bunch of new things
that we didn't really
have great answers for
at Spotify at the time.
It used to be very painful
for teams to deploy changes
to their services.
They'd frequently fail.
Rolling back from a failed
deployment was pretty tricky.
And as a result,
people, teams just
would not deploy very often
because there was a lot of risk
and pain with that.
So we were very
interested in Docker
because we thought that
building containers would
make it a lot simpler.
We could just have--
deployments would
be a lot simpler.
And if you just want to roll
back, because each container is
kind of atomic and
totally separated,
that would be very simple.
Another big benefit is that
it was just a lot easier
for developers to run
the service themselves
on their laptop, even
if it didn't really
look like production.
So the main reason we were
super interested in Docker
to start with was just to
make deploying easier, making
running services
easier, and then
to increase the
rate at which people
were deploying changes and just
being productive, basically.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And is
there anything, looking back
on that, at least the first
chunk of that transition,
that you wish you
did differently?
MATT BROWN: I
would say one thing
that I wish we did a
little bit differently--
we were very conscious
as an infrastructure team
that we're changing out
basically the platform
that we run applications
on in production, which
was working pretty fine before.
It had some features that were
missing that we wish we had.
But things weren't on fire
or anything like that.
So we wanted to be
very sure that what
we move people to
is super stable,
they don't really
notice any problems,
and it's just all
positives for them to move.
I think as a part of that, we
probably were a little hesitant
to take risks.
And we didn't want, really,
any team to move their service
fully to Kubernetes until we
were, as an infrastructure
team, 110% prepared for that.
In retrospect, I think we could
have accepted some more risk.
The engineers on all of our
teams building these services,
they know better than we do as
an infrastructure team which
services are super
important, which
services are internal facing
and not important at all
and can stand some downtime.
So think we could have let them
take some more risk and tell us
what would be--
like do some more
experiments themselves.
And we probably would
have just learned
a few things a
little bit faster.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Are
there other things
that you wish you
did more of as you
were going through this
transition process?
MATT BROWN: I think one thing
that we found that surprised us
as we did this is we didn't
have to do as much selling
or evangelizing of the move to
GKE to the engineering teams
at Spotify.
Part of that's because they
already knew about Kubernetes.
Obviously, it's talked about
quite a lot in the development
community.
But also, we found that some
early-adopting teams were
really happy with the results.
And so they would go out
and talk to other teams
and give talks at an internal
conference that we do or just--
they would try to
motivate their peers.
So I wish one thing we could
have done more of perhaps
is try to take
advantage of that,
create more
champions internally.
Because those engineers who
did that work were really
the best selling point that we
had for convincing other teams
to spend time on this.
MAX SALTONSTALL: If you
enjoyed this episodes,
check out the Stack Chat
playlist for more videos.